[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're tackling the issue of
self-promotion the question is how do we
feel about self-promotion there's a lot
of it we never promote ourselves
constantly we're constantly making stuff
and then you got to promote it and I'm
not you know I'm not apologizing for it
and I would say there's a lot like
college not just we promote ourselves
all the time in our own work in our own
properties right yeah this is not we're
not gonna talk about that as much as
we're gonna talk about when you got to
go on other people's shows make media
appearances have a media day and promote
yourself yeah so we're gonna pull back
the curtain on what that's like what our
experience is what our raw assessment of
that it seems like we have a negative
view on it by the by the tone of a
conversation at this point slightly
mixed so cuz mixed we're just fresh off
of our bleak creeks and we're just fresh
we're just fresh I mean look at us all
black man look at this look at these
guys
where are these guys going I'm actually
not that fresh I'm a little bit
jet-lagged you know we're recording this
on a what is it what day is it - Tuesday
- Tuesday I feel I feel better today you
got back Saturday don't feel like you
bounced a little bit today no into the
gym when I go to the gym see that's it
going to the gym bounces you into the
into the day I thought about not going
and you should have gone you should go
man cuz I thought good or it's gonna go
I want to fight some I was gonna go
yester sometimes I get that feeling I
want to fight somebody I'm in that mood
right now well you know you're not gonna
get that from me if you stop fighting me
I'm just going roll into a ball and kind
of dressed like a boxer you know like
it's got a good ian is wearing a hoodie
black hoodies well yeah they wear
hoodies do things like this they wear
sweatpants and they jog they were like
and they jump broke up when they come to
the weigh-in they pull their hoodie over
their hat and sometimes they also have
headphones on like this I kind of feel
like
I should get into that music - is it too
late to get get into that Logan Paul
thing I think that's probably that's
probably ready happened by the time
you're hearing this when when when when
fighters weigh-in and they're wearing
headphones doesn't that doesn't that
make them way more yes when you want to
wait is when you want to go up to the
next level please count my headphones no
you come you come to the weigh-in like
that and then you strip down into some
colorful Underpants that's what that's
the way I do it at least so what I was
trying to say was we are fresh off the
bleak heat conversations tour you know
for the past week prior to recording
this episode we've we've been touring
doing what you might think is just a
book tour but we we tried to make it
really special and like we had that the
the documentary of us going back to
Buies Creek and then like making all the
connections how that ties in to bleak
creek and we also released I don't good
mythical morning so we're basking in the
in the in the public response to that
which is I'm very encouraged by oh yeah
but again with the time change in the
and being on the road and a lot of
flights and a lot of self-promotion a
lot of talking about yourself in other
people's places you know well so we're
gonna unpack what that experience is
like but coming back home to my place
like it means it's it's so important to
me yeah you know you start thinking
about yeah I want to be I'm a bit I
wanna be in my bed and wanna be on my
toilet I want to be on my couch I'm
gonna be in my backyard I want to be
with my family and my dog you know I
started thinking about that's not pining
for these things especially when in
self-promotion mode so we took yesterday
off we didn't see or talk to each other
so let's start there let's start with it
with our yesterday's I I had an
interesting yesterday Christie had a had
a proposal for me I was like ain't let's
let's hang out
sent two kids off to school and she's
like let's go get a pedicure and I'm
like okay any anytime you're paying
somebody to like do something to you
I'm I'm up for that you know a little
self pampering but what I forgot I i
pedicure suck I've had a pedicure once I
don't like people taint it was it was on
it was it was at the hotel we were
staying at and I think like Cabo or
something with Christina that's the only
that's the only time I've had one and I
had forgotten that I decided at that
time that I did not like pedicures I
didn't want another one yeah that's what
I decided I remembered that when I was
getting this pedicure yesterday here's
the thing that I specifically remembered
it's not just that and I agree with you
I don't like people I don't like people
touching my feet for the longest time
when I got a massage I would say Nick's
the feet I still say that I don't I
don't want the feet you know there's
like some tickling involved but here's
the thing for me it brought back
traumatic childhood memories I was
deathly afraid of my toenails being
clipped I certainly wouldn't do it
myself and my mom wouldn't I would throw
what I call a conniption I would throw a
tantrum and start what age you talking
about
as young as I can remember
I mean maybe four or five years old but
I think it I'm pretty sure it continued
into at least like second grade so after
I knew you I wasn't I wouldn't hit my
stepdad Jimmy mom had to call Jimmy and
like grab my ankles and hold him down so
that she could clip my toenails like
when I was you scared of I was afraid of
being cut and like bleeding happening
like man I'm really afraid of like
trimming nails too short
that oh that's like nails on a
chalkboard to me that doesn't it doesn't
freak you out
you ever had a nail cut too short oh
yeah that's not I mean I don't look I
don't look forward to it
it hurts it only phobia and then what
makes it even worse is that then you
have to wait for it like for a week or
so for it to grow out to the point where
it doesn't feel like I just start to
feel like my whole in
my fingers gonna suck yeah now Ben I
have nail problems I mean like you see
what's happening there
oh no see that see how it detaches you
got on a white and white and it's not
like a French manicure hit psoriasis so
you get psoriasis under your nail beds
and it in the nail detaches so this will
go all the way down sometimes and then
it'll just go from I thought you
determined that was from diet no no I
diet would fix it well my diet causes it
to not be nearly as bad but yeah I still
have flare-ups there's none on this hand
right now but you have it on your
toenails too not as much on my toenails
but you can see like if what if I were
to cut that down that nail down to where
it needs to be like there's a lot of
like fleshy part like that's a normal
this is a normal person's nail like yeah
the nail goes to the end of the finger
yeah that's great but that doesn't
happen on any of my fingers anymore
except that index finger because I've
got nail problems well I'm in there and
this like I had to start like doing some
deep breathing techniques I didn't want
to complain or like bolt out of there I
was like maybe I can maybe this is like
therapeutic for me like facing my fears
that's not what the pedicure is about
though I mean I appreciate about
changing perspective but I'm like you're
supposed to enjoy it I'm doing some like
deep belly breathing and like and then
on my my big toe
apparently she yeah I wouldn't say I
have an ingrown toenail what she did it
kind of goes it goes in on the side and
I cut the thing a little too short so
then she's like digging in there like
trying to do some sort of operation and
I'm like oh gosh this is this is
horrible does your wife enjoy it or did
she enjoy the results I think she enjoys
some people don't want a little bit of a
leg massage some people don't mind their
feet being touched
I got a yeah I don't enjoy like the foot
massage part of a massage just makes me
laugh I cannot just enjoy it
it feels it either feels it like it's
ticklish
or it just feels incredibly
uncomfortable but there's no like it
doesn't feel soothing in any way and
trying not to laugh
makes it more uncomfortable right
because then you're like you're kind of
like squirming because you don't want to
laugh like why not just come out and
laugh because laughter is a nice release
because then you just seem like the
Joker
I don't do that and just laughing in
awkward no I think they would understand
that like hey it's tickle Dave Dave
encountered a ticklish person before
yeah so it's not like they would think
you're demented or something
how do your toes look though how your
nails look great good
they weren't painted or anything uh I
would definitely if I'm gonna take that
much time for something that's
definitely got to be a massage next time
I can't it can't be the pedicure yeah
but I think there are people who like
they never let anybody touch their toes
I know I said that backwards they never
touched them to their toes themselves
they only let other people do it so it's
just like oh I don't I don't trim my
nails somebody does that for me
you think that's true that's got to be
the case I'd say a lot of people rich
rich ladies yeah yeah yeah rich ladies
don't let don't touch their toenails
people do it it's hard to get down there
and I really give it a detailed working
I didn't get a pedicure yesterday what
did you get manicure manicure yeah you
know I did think about getting a
manicure I'm not gonna let anybody know
what are people gonna do with that
there's nothing there's nothing they can
do oh they could do a lot shinier up
trim it down but time time those
cuticles the the unfortunate thing is
that both of my kids were sick and had
to stay home from school oh and and so
then Jesse was like well help I mean I
feel like we should stay here with them
and I'm like I feel like we should leave
them to themselves
[Laughter]
dad got a day off he was thinking he was
going to get to have a day date with his
wife yeah and so I still wanted that to
happen
sure and she was like well what are they
gonna eat I was like well there's a
kitchen you know there's a kitchen there
there's food in the house how sick were
they were they like bedridden or just
like said we're like it was
a cold and maybe a little bit of a fever
for Shepherd so it was like this
wouldn't be responsible that this would
be responsible to let them go to school
yeah so did you leave them yeah we did
you win yeah and then when you came back
where they are I was still there yes
Jesse would say things like she was -
told him she said okay there's some
pasta there's some pasta in the
refrigerator that you can't like some
ravioli type thing you know okay it's
like the it's the it's in a fancy
Italian section of the I call it the
fancy Italian section of the frozen of
the the cold part of the grocery store
where it's like the pasta that isn't
frozen it's in that plastic oh yeah and
you can throw it in there and boil it up
and you feel a little bit more like a
chef all you did was boil some pasta but
it was never frozen so it's like yeah
it's never frozen so it feels fancy yeah
feels kind of like you know the Italian
food version of a pedicure yeah so so
you give it you're just throwing that at
the kids well they can make that lot can
boil that and then look Jesse's like
well what if he doesn't turn the stove
off
I like well it'll just be you know it'll
be a stove that is on right yeah because
yeah stoves can be on right how long a
stove is on doesn't necessarily increase
the danger right but the this the burner
could be off but the gas could still be
on then you got a process the problem
but that's kind of hard to do yeah but I
did I did text Locke and said Amen if
you turn the stove on make sure you turn
it off he's like okay and when you got
home what was burned nothing nothing was
burned good they had they were had full
bellies and well what did you do I went
to a restaurant okay
had a brunches thing kind of brunch and
then we went grocery shopping oh yeah
now we're to it yeah
romance when I met I could spend a lot
of time at Whole Foods really yeah yeah
Whole Foods
it hopefully is kind of like that there
is a sense of discovery when you go
there yeah unless you go there a lot I
don't I don't go there a lot
so you yeah so it's kind of like whoa
they got they got this fancy they've got
a lot of fancy crap well and then it's
like I want to come home and I wanted to
grill something okay and they just have
the meat section it's just so impressive
the meat section the have you seen the
meat section no Whole Foods I mean it
puts other meat sections to shame I'm
more of a like bet the weird beverage
they got were beverage peanut butter
spread sections they got that - what
what did you get chicken thighs that
doesn't seem odd no I mean it seemed
very there was a lot of things that I
could have gotten that I couldn't have
gotten anywhere else like they had a
giant just a giant tomahawk steak oh
yeah just I mean that's kind of a scene
you know like I don't even know if it
would fill my grill you don't want to
mess that up and can't go wrong with
chicken thighs I do want to get one of
those at one point daddy
cook took cooks a tomahawk and then I
just come in holding it by the bone and
let the family eat off of it like a
giant meat drumstick you could rent like
a cave you could like I'll go into a
cave no I want to do it where like skins
you could show up with a big hunk of
meat and but no I got chicken thighs man
chicken thighs can't beat a good chicken
thigh on the grill man I put some rub on
them boneless no I wouldn't I went
bone-in skin-on oh yeah even though I
talked about getting boneless but jesse
is like no no you gotta get the bone in
you gotta get and I understand why it's
just a little it's a little nastier to
eat because it's because it's because of
the dark meat and you get down to the
right next to the bone and no matter how
well you've cooked it it's a little pink
right next to the bone and you're kind
of like did I cook this enough and
you're asking yourself that question but
no I put some rub on them and then I
cooked them on some hot coals charcoal
then I put some barbecue sauce on it the
and let it caramelize a little bit you
know blacking them up a little bit also
grilled some poblano peppers along with
them the California roasted poblanos cut
those up put him in the middle of table
you could have them along with your
chicken everybody was happy with dad for
a little for at least for a little bit
okay that's good but your toes though my
toes were in shoes the whole time no I
think you're totally work I've seen him
occasionally those in there I mean I
think you could use really stand up
benefits not a it needs to be done no
it's it's not a lack of care it has
nothing to do it care it's genetics
yeah okay I could get I can buff it and
shape it and do and do something why for
who who would it be for you it's not for
me I don't care I feel like the way your
nails grow they like grow up and out no
they grow they they hug they hug the end
of the toe you know they don't they
don't grow out they just go around the
toe that's good maybe you never need to
kind of crawl like a it's like it's like
your toes have a helmet if you let it
keep growing um a little nail hell I
keep them trimmed for the most part it's
just you know there's some real long
ways for you they're just unsightly if
you get down the under that toe I don't
try it to be honest with you and this is
probably is this probably sexist I just
don't trust a man with good-looking feet
you know I just I I feel like he's up to
something
that explains why whenever we have an
important meeting or interview you you
ask people to take off their shoes and
socks right and if it's a man and he has
like spectacular feet I'm like some you
know I don't know I don't know if I can
trust you yeah that's probably sexist
it's probably multiple things I'm just
being honest
speaking of being honest I want to be
honest about what it's like to to do the
self-promotion so we're gonna get into
that well we were I think on the
calendar we called it media day this was
the day in particular we did a number of
things but the day that I am thinking
about impetus
is Monday of this past week when we're
recording this in which we had to in New
York City we had to get up I'm just
gonna give a overview of the day and
then we can get into the details okay we
had to get up get dressed go to the
Today Show first I think so yeah
then we had to go to Conde Nast
who owns wire wired and Vanity Fair do
three videos yeah them and then
immediately go to the Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon and then go directly from
The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon to
doubly creeks conversations and that's
why we showed up at that particular show
in our suits when I say it like that it
doesn't feel like it was a whole lot but
it certainly felt like a whole lot at
the time well especially with the time
change I mean it's three hours different
so you're you're having to get up and
you let's just say three hours earlier
than we normally would definitely not
yet adjusted yeah so that's kind of and
it was and it was the second or third
day of having been on the time you know
that's when the jetlag really hits so it
was it was pretty difficult but I mean
you go on the Today Show with all these
I mean with the television shows it's
true Fallon is true The Today Show
and any other appearance like that you
do this pre-interview where you're kind
of talking to the producer in order to
you know they know what you want to
promote it's like we're talking to them
about the novel so that they can find a
touch point that works with their
audience so they can ask us a question
that then you know we can say something
that will resonate but then you also you
know you got to try to get a funny story
in there or like play a game or a pay
apparently you know they're throwing
more and more things at at guest
appearances in order to get people to
watch them we can unpack that more but I
think when we went to the tonight The
Today Show and The Tonight Show so that
we kind of knew based on
the pre-interview with the producers
what it is we were gonna be doing but I
will say that that interview went it was
very short but it went a lot it actually
wasn't what we had been asked in the
pre-interview unlike Fallon which we can
get into in a second but I you know it's
um well let's back up a little bit and
talk about thinking about what we were
gonna wear because okay that was the
first thing to happen so all right
we have I was wonderful stylist Kimi
Erin who is the the person who helps us
figure out what we're gonna wear when we
make these media appearances if you
think that we look good on Jimmy Fallon
you can thank Kimmy Erin mm-hmm
and she also put together these looks
for the Today Show and then we had
another day of Chicago thing yeah
so I think that we have this we've
discussed this we're comfortable in two
different modes typically when it comes
to what we're wearing and that is casual
whatever we would wear on give them
Ithaca which is whatever we would wear
on gmn which is basically what we would
wear you know if I was just getting up
and going about my day right and then we
have very dressed up sharply dressed
like we were on Fallon full suit tie
socks that match etc I like to wear I
like to wear it's fun to get dressed up
every now and again and we're so when is
something that's important to us that
you know you can be just if I get in
that fancy and a lot of people the night
show a lot of people take a different
tack when they go on The Tonight Show so
uh Tyler ninja even on The Tonight Show
and a hoodie he was dressed like I am
right now like a like a boxer getting
ready to well let's do it let's say a
gamer yes just like a gamer and so he
was like and okay I'm in there every
everybody does a different thing it's
like weird I know I'm I said we're gonna
dress up but the there's this what you
might call a no-man's land for us yeah
which is this
you call it business casual well it's
called the way we looked on the Today
Show yeah so I had this like black
jacket over a turtleneck and these tan
pants and these black shoes I would very
rarely if ever choose to wear any of
these things for myself right I mean I
thought you look good in it I mean the
pants that I wore were purple pants from
a suit that I had but then I had this
sweater
that's like thin very dressy block
pattern sweater that I thought yours was
a little less I actually wouldn't I
would wear that on like a nice date but
not really not in LA there's very few
places where yeah you go on a nice date
but you don't go out at least I don't
like go out for a date in LA even at a
really nice restaurant I'm wearing like
wear a blazer yeah I don't just like put
a blazer on over stuff
I just that so but that weird in-between
stage is I just can't find a way to be
comfortable but for the Today Show we
were given that we were we we were given
something in this middle zone the thing
is we had a choice I will say that we
have a choice so Kimmy comes in she has
a spread of different clothes and she's
and so she's going for this sort of
updated like well I would say elevated
casual a little bit dressed up but a
little bit dressed down look for the
Today Show because that if you look at
what people wear on the Today Show
that's what they wear and so and also
you're thinking about like it's funny
because we have conversations with our
publishers who says things like you know
mostly moms are going to be watching The
Today Show at the hour that you're going
to be on in the fourth hour of The Today
Show and so you we want to we want you
to impress moms right and you can say
something about the book that would make
them want to buy the book for their
teenager so then we picked out these
outfits that we just described to you
and then we packed them and then we're
like we're talking on the flight we're
like man it's like we're like fretting
about these outfits we're like man this
I don't know be comfortable
I'm saying things like you know your
jackets so big you're already so big
it's like you make me look small why you
gotta wear this big ass jacket that
makes me look even smaller and so like
that's my qualms and you're like well
I'm not even comfortable wearing this
anyway
I we don't have to talk about that but I
think that's in your mind it is it yeah
it was my it was my overthinking of the
ensemble but you're like I don't even
want to wear this anyway I don't feel
like it's it's not us I don't feel as
comfortable it's like all the stuff that
you just said and so then we tell Jenna
we're like so we're thinking about not
wearing the clothes that can be picked
up we're thinking about wearing the
slightly less dressy clothes that she
picked out for the Chicago thing on the
Today Show yeah so she's like okay I'll
get those ready and then we're gonna
we're gonna text from Stevie his TV's
like so I heard you two guys are
thinking about not wearing the the
clothes that can be picked out for you
for today's show oh here we go
[Laughter]
because I could tell and this is not
this is obviously we have an incredible
relationship with Stevie and we've been
working with her for how many years has
it been seven or eight years and this is
the nature this is often in nature of
our relationship this is what we want
her to do in fact when you wished her
happy birthday the other day yes I thank
you for disappointing us disagreeing
with us and blankety-blank
right because she's very good at what
she does and she's usually right and so
she was like well I do think that you do
you want this to be an elevated look you
are trying to impress moms and I think
that and she'd like sends us the
pictures up because we take once you get
through in the wardrobe you take a
picture of yourself she's like this is
what you're thinking about wearing but
this is what you could be wearing I
think you should go with what you could
be wearing and she's probably right but
I just want to be comfortable and does
it really matter anyway who's gonna
watch this I thought I started thinking
things like this
is this is going on this show and
talking about this book for 45 seconds
gonna make anybody buy it anyway like
that's the kind of I started thinking
it's easy to start thinking that
especially when you start doing it but
yeah I'm like listen okay we're not
gonna die on this hill like Jenna
brought these clothes in but then but
then Jenna so we had that conversation
with Stevie I was like okay we'll keep
talking about it I didn't make neither
of us made a definitive decision and you
got off of the tech tech threat I think
he went work to work out or something am
I gonna talk about this yeah so after
some back-and-forth with Stevie then I
text Jenna I'm like okay well we may
wear the other clothes and she was like
I thought you might say that and I'm
already got them ready yeah and then she
was and then she was like I agree that
that's what you should wear
so okay Jenna and Stevie now both think
that this is what we should be wearing
to impress all the moms watching The
Today Show in the fourth hour and so
that's what we did you know it it in a
solid game so I'm looking this looking
at this as like a case study there's two
different ways you can look at this as
as a listener I'm thinking one is yeah
this is a game and maybe you can see how
it gets it can start to wear on you
because it's like listen no pun intended
okay I'm wearing something that I
wouldn't naturally where even on a date
and but I'm doing it so that I can reach
this perceive mom demographic it's like
yeah but then on the other hand it's
like you got somebody who's bringing in
like a spread of clothes and we just
going you know we're trying all this
stuff on and somebody makes this look
elevated and isn't that fun you know and
I mean it's definitely fun too and it is
I think both are true
you know it's especially when you talk
about the suits and like being able to
like look your finest and go on The
Tonight Show for not the first but like
the I think the sixth time yeah you know
that's freaking awesome so it's like no
it's great I we're not complaining it's
just it's just I we think
it's amusing the the games that you have
to play when it comes to marketing well
I will say that in the moment in the
moment it is difficult for me to enjoy
yeah I am often when that day when I saw
I knew that day was coming right I was
like okay we're gonna do the Today Show
and the day by the way for those of you
might be confused if you were following
along during the week that we were we
recorded the Today Show but then it shot
aired that Thursday or Friday so but all
this was done on the same day I was
thinking about that day and you have so
little control in those situations like
when you for every situation that we
were going into you're it's it's we're
not in control we're not hosting it's
we're on somebody else's show mm-hm
and I definitely don't look forward to
it I actually start thinking about I had
these like fantasies about being in my
hotel room at the end of the night going
to bed yeah and that's not a that is not
necessarily a healthy way to see that
day when you wake up in the morning
you're thinking about oh I just want to
be back here going to bed because I am
anxious about the stuff that I have to
do you know you know and I don't want to
over blow it I'm not like it's not a
debilitating it's not like a true it's
not like an anxiety disorder I don't I'm
not like super uncomfortable it's just
like I have trouble getting myself to
enjoy this I'd rather be doing this on
my own terms you know but then you know
and in the moment especially depending
on what it was I think you know when we
were on Fallon and we were performing a
song that we had written we were 14 I
was legitimately having a good time yeah
at that point yeah that was amazing
before the Today Show I mean I mean the
morning shows are like zoos I mean it's
just like with all the cages open it's
just everybody's going everywhere and
cramped quarters and you're being you're
being shoved here to wait and then come
out here and then oh let's meet the host
and oh they're putting blindfolds on you
and you're eating a sandwich that they
made it's like we knew we're gonna do
that and that was funny and then
the interview and it was like okay we
knew we were gonna we're gonna get a
couple of questions about the book we
get the first question
and we cuz you want to talk to the moms
about the novel yeah you know we got all
dressed up for your mom we're gonna hear
you want to hear about this novel and so
they ask you what's the novel about and
I and you're like sharing what the novel
is about and then I'm like okay I know
what my follow-up is just to kind of
clarify you know what I think is gonna
resonate with the viewer but I didn't
even have a chance to get that in
because they move so quickly you're
giving your answer about like the brief
synopsis of the lost causes of bleak
Creek and right on the heels of that she
says you guys want to play a game where
we zoom in on food and you guess what it
is
I was like wow okay sure so you know
I've heard Joe Rogan talk it's like
being in a rock tumbler i Joe Rogan has
talked about the fact that it he's like
I hate doing morning radio and I don't
want to do like appearances and
interviews so I just had this podcast
and I just tell people that I'm gonna be
somewhere and they come to my shows and
they sell out because and you know what
he can do that because he has the most
popular podcast in the world we can't do
that if we just told you guys on GMM and
your biscuits about what we were doing a
lot less people would find out about it
so we don't have the privilege of being
able to make that but I understand the
impulse because even the way podcasting
in general I mean obviously we don't do
interviews anymore but you know the way
that everything is put into these really
bite-sized pieces even when you've got a
daily show like - Today Show which I
guess goes for four is it four hours
every day listen I don't know it's at
least four hours every day and well at
least three because we were in the
fourth they say we were in the fourth
hour so it's got to be at least four
hours right yeah that's when they say
they don't worry about the news anymore
and they started zooming in on pictures
of right and so if you have got to talk
and fill that time every single day you
would think this might be a play
for a slightly slower paced relaxed
conversation about something but no even
in that four hours of content there's
gonna be what's your book about you say
one line and you say all right let's
play a game where we zoom in on food
that's just the nature of the medium I'm
not necessarily complaining about it but
I'm just saying you have to know that
that is the environment you're going
into as opposed to when we made the
appearance on the dead meat podcast and
and Pete Holmes podcast yeah we're in
the books on a subway podcast which we
any podcast any podcast you can be like
I'm going to talk about this at my own
pace and I'm gonna get to say the things
that I want to say about it
which by the way if if you're I do
recommend you listen to those podcasts
we get in if you if you're reading the
novel right now and you're into the
details of it but you you want a spoiler
free conversation dead meat James pocket
dead meat podcast was a really fun
discuss James in Chelsea and then
similarly spoiler free podcast
conversation on books on the subway like
off the rails conversation that one went
places so yeah and then particularly for
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
two hours of talking about a lot of
topics that in in you know using the
book as a jumping-off point we talked
about lots of lots of things
in the realm of faith that you I don't
think we've ever talked about so if
you're interested in that definitely
check out our guest you know Pete's
podcast but yeah when it comes to
podcasting in that that pacing
podcasting gives me hope because it is
that conversation was drawn-out go in
deep I mean what we're doing right now
is rewarding it's a rewarding experience
for us and I'm just glad that people
want to listen well I think there's also
an authenticity to the platform not just
that you could rest a little more
elevated I'm just saying exactly so it's
like
why are we why are we worrying about
this pretence and that as you listen to
us talk about this you I'm sure because
you've chosen to listen to a podcast
you've chosen to make guys who make
primarily Internet videos a part of your
entertainment landscape
mm-hmm if you've made that decision then
you probably have chosen that because
you have a distaste for the traditional
traditional way things are done you're
not watching this Today Show you don't
want to see these prepackaged clips that
are moving at this ridiculous pace you
you you don't want to think about oh
those guys are dressed like that not
because it's who they are but it's who
they think someone else wants them to be
I understand that that might be a huge
turnoff we're just kind of being really
honest about the way that we're talking
about it because it is a game when you
go into someone else's territory and
you're the whole point is to be there to
appeal to their audience so very frankly
you can sell more books because you
believe in what you've created and you
want to be able to write more and you
want this thing to break outside of your
fan base you kind of have to swallow
some of those things well you don't have
to but we have chosen to without any
shame to swallow some of those things
but I but I would say that it is the
more laid-back more authentic new media
appearances that are more fun but in you
know the traditional television media
it's you see how they're they're being
informed by the internet like your point
about the Today Show was you'd think
that by the fourth hour that they could
stretch things out and get a little more
conversational obviously that's not the
case because we're sitting there like
quickly I mean our segment was so short
even in the fourth hour
if you don't zoom in on food somebody's
gonna turn it to Good Morning America
apparently right the theory but it well
it really I mean it it kind of mirrors
what what's happening online in terms of
clickbait and you've yet or I'll say the
way that even the Tonight Show and all
the talk shows
have to create content and then works on
the Internet
you know so it's I mean we found
ourselves in situations that were not
that different than good mythical
morning because of how the landscape is
changing perfect example
the next day we we've we flew to Chicago
and we were on the Windy City I think is
the name of the show it's like I think
it's the ABC actually it yeah the
Chicago version of The Today Show
basically or Good Morning America and
you know what that's actually airing
today we are recording this we never set
we never sat down and had an interview
we said a couple of things about the
novel they held it up they plugged it
but we played this game what did I call
it I don't know but it was it was
feeling squealing yes what your hand in
a box and then you guess what what it is
you're feeling now the night before on
The Tonight Show the the guest before us
was Reese Witherspoon and when she first
came out she put her hand in a box and
tried to figure out what it is she was
feeling
she played feeling squeal now I'm not
saying that the Tonight Show in the
Windy City have copied us and something
we invented I don't even know if we
invented it was it was an idea that was
waiting to have Vanity Fair did
something called the fear box and it was
very much the same thing we were doing
with feeling squeal but and who cares if
it was before or after it's an obvious
idea once you start thinking of let's
have guests do things but that's what
everybody's doing now is that you find
yourself in Chicago on a morning show
and they're playing the same they're
playing the same thing that Fallon's
playing something that we're playing and
not to mention on The Today Show the
hole is zooming in on something and
guessing what it is well we've done that
as well again yes isn't a hey we did it
first I we're not saying we did it first
but there's a we make a show that is the
the pieces of the traditional shows that
are designed to then be viral or to
break out or to make it seem more fun
well we have a show that is built
primarily with those sensational things
in good mythical morning and so the
conversation that we started having
yeah was and again I I think we talk
about this all the time I mean while
we're traveling and while we're supposed
to be enjoying hey we got a book that's
out and people are responding well to it
and we get to go on The Today Show and
we get to go on Fallon we just continue
it's our mode to just continue to work
and to discuss and to figure out what
we're gonna do next I actually have more
fun doing that than not doing it so it's
fine but what we kept saying was hmm you
know we're constantly trying to innovate
in lots of different ways but also
within good mythical morning and it's
just like when you go to a for lack of a
better word a local news show in Chicago
and they're doing the thing that you do
on your show it's kind of like when your
mom got on Facebook and yeah like I
don't think Facebook is formula anymore
yeah the thing that we started thinking
is all right we got to do something else
now that they're doing it for the moms
now we got to do something new that they
if they can copy that if they want but I
kind of feel like the pressure to be
like alright this has gotten all the way
to this point let's let's find something
else which is what which is it's a
conversation we're constantly having
we're constant rying to invent new
things but especially towards the
towards the end of a year when we're
like we're starting to think
strategically about what 2020 looks like
we're just scratching the surface of
that conversation but when it comes to
good mythical morning it's like as we
talked about with your biscuits evolve
or die and we don't have the answers and
so I actually I'm at a pretty unsettled
point because I settled I think we've
started even with a fresh pedicure
you're still on sorry yeah sadly I
understand because I think we've we've
identified this challenge and we said
and we've you know you you read the tea
leaves in the Windy City show and it's
like if they're doing what we're doing
then we need to be doing something else
so it's like percent so it's like not
know
mean what that is and and absolutely
knowing that it's not it's not a big
drastic change that happens overnight
you know and the the way that
everything's set up with a way that we
produce good mythical morning it's more
like how do we how do we how do we
continue to evolve not how do we
drastically change what the show is but
even within that evolution like knowing
strategically like what do we what's the
what's the long view it identifying the
problem but they're not yet have any
answers to me as an unsettling point and
I think we I think we I feel a little
bit more engaged in the challenge of it
right now then I then I have over the
past few years I think when it comes to
good mythical morning yeah I agree with
that and it's by no means not the only
challenge that we're facing
I mean creatively there's lots of things
I think it was it was interesting that
we've been having this conversation
about innovation and then we go and
basically every single appearance that
we make well like a list well also let's
talk about the fact that you know we I
don't I don't know when those videos are
gonna come out the ones that we shot for
Vanity Fair but well just talk about him
it don't matter you know we did it we
basically did a lie-detector thing right
well we already done a lie detector
thing we done a lie detector thing on
our show and you've also with our moms
but that's not what you tell me we've
done a lie detector thing for BuzzFeed I
think like two years ago right and now
we're doing another lie detector thing
with whatever outlet that was Vanity
Fair and so I think it's a funny video
but you what you start you start to get
this sense that everyone is doing the
saint's they're seeing they're looking
out they're seeing what works and then
they're trying to do it some people just
do it exactly the way that they've seen
it done and it works yeah until it stops
working and so and I think we have to be
the ones to find the next things that
we're gonna try that other people will
emulate well it's an innocent
it's a tall order and we and we have it
really an incredible team in there
coming up with things all yeah when I
say we I mean all of us as a team I'm
not just talking about the two of them
but I'm just saying that it's the
question that's in my mind right now and
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
articulate it this way in a way to make
sense to even me or anyone else try it
in Spanish well that would be even
harder
that would be muy difficile hey you've
proven your para is I think I just
wasn't French yeah el francais yeah all
right Frances close to it you said you
didn't know some people who probably
speak Fran ish you said you know if you
could articulate your point and then I
made it even more difficult I'm sorry
that's what you specialize in that Oh
pedicures Andy railing but the it would
have been funny if you two just ignored
it
I don't want I said no if to me it feels
like it's not just finding the next box
to stick your hand in right what's the
next version of a box to stick your hand
in a box to stick your foot in you know
what I'm saying like there you can get
you can get really close to it but
really what we're talking about we're
talking about a genre we're not talking
there's an evolution within a genre and
then there's the genre of it there's an
evolution of the genre evolution within
the genre or evolution of the genre
right cuz how yeah and I mean in you
because you talk about food you talk
about us eating so much food you can you
can find different ways to no planet
that's it and you know it's like okay
well let's eat things from different
places
I specifically remember yeah you know we
still do come up with some ideas I
specifically remember when the
international food thing was birthed
birth or pitched to us and it was like
hey we're gonna play a game where you
guys eat something from international
fast food location around the world and
then you have to guess what country it
comes from and then I was like is there
can we may
get physical can we make like what if we
had a map and we threw darts at it and
that was the way that you guessed and
that became a format that like no one
else is doing right and then when we the
shuffleboard thing it was an answer to
hey let's guess when things came from
and what's a fun way to like interact
physically with the timeline and
somebody was like shuffleboard and so
not now we do that with shuffleboard
yeah and then went on our last tool we
started throw an axis so I come back and
I'm like now in the same genre in the
same we also call it a bucket of like
the guessing using some physical
challenge and let's do that what axis
now we haven't done that yet but we're
gonna do it I'm just saying we're gonna
do it so yeah I might does it before us
it has already done it I don't know
about it and we are gonna do it it's
tough to keep up with who's done what
that's for sure and there's a lot of
like convergent idea ideation on the
Internet where you end up doing the same
thing just because everyone is thinking
everyone is this is the this is what I'm
trying to articulate in in Furnish yeah
is that everyone is I da ting in the
same landscape kind of in the same ways
and I think that and I don't know if
we're capable of it let me just say I
don't know if we're capable of it and I
don't know if you can do it within GMM
and not kill it
but I think the challenge that we're
trying to approach is just like how do
you level up the genre as opposed to
just reinventing the wheel and just
making it a little bit flashier of a
wheel yeah in the conversation cuz you
look at Fallon how long can fell and
just have top-notch celebrity guests
come in and put their hands in things or
drink things at the same stuff that
we're doing you can probably do it a lot
longer than we have because there's a
television institution and as much as
I'd like to think and maybe for some
people GMM is starting to feel like an
Internet institution it's like we cannot
we can't rest on on that whether it's
true or false I don't know it doesn't
matter to me at this point and you know
what matters is is
creating things that we that were
excited about within the context of the
show if I'm just looking at the show and
then you know that we also think will
work and that it that is a challenge I
mean when I on one stop on the bleed
Creek conversations we would always
answer questions from from the audience
that were tweeted at us and one question
let's see cuz I'm trying to remember I
don't actually don't remember the
question but the answer was basically
well why do we why do we want to write a
novel and we talked about our passion
for storytelling and our erics once we
had the opportunity than our excitement
to mine our shared experiences and our
friendship and like pour that into a
novel and so much of it was about story
though but then the thing in my answer
was there was another side benefit
something we didn't anticipate with
saying yes to the huge project of
writing a novel and that was it really
got us back in touch with the roots of
our friendship mmm
so yes we want we created that
documentary in order to make the
connections between the novel and our
friendship in order to I mean not just
to sell the book but I mean honestly as
part of it but yeah but then it became
such a such an important project just
the documentary part I think it was so
important to us to reconnect with our
friendship that we wanted to make sure
that not only ticket holders to the
conversation events but everyone who
wanted to see it who's a fan of ours
could see it that's why we put it out as
three episodes ago morning as we're
recording this we're in the middle of
the second day and we're already seeing
the response I don't know how many views
it'll end up getting you know I think
it's I think part one is doing pretty
well it's here's the ironic thing right
this documentary of us going back to our
childhood homes and part one is
literally visiting our where we the
homes we grew up in is not taking off as
fast as a video that's just about food
right however there are a lot of people
who are voicing their opinions about it
and saying I love
seeing this kind of content from you I
love when you guys get out into the
world and and obviously you can't
there's no there is no world in which we
turn good mythical morning into that
because I think even if you've never
edited a video in your life you probably
have some appreciation for the fact that
those duck does documentary the
three-part documentary was a lot harder
to put together than an episode of good
mythical morning like exponentially more
time went into this sure so we can't
that can't become good mythical more and
that's not what's on the pacing the
people's response to it because it it
literally is taking putting into the GMM
flow something that's completely
completely unexpected and completely
outside of the genre that we've
established it I'm not saying this
always we're gonna move into that
direction I'm just saying that it shakes
things up and it gets us it gets our
minds working well I think in a
different way I think I'm one thing that
we know it already did was I hope this
happened I think that it it reminded
people that the reason why good mythical
morning works is because of the deeply
rooted friendship it's not just about
what are they gonna eat and gag into a
trash can you know and I found I fell
myself seeing that in answering a
question at the conversations last week
and then people started applauding it's
like that that I mean why didn't we
didn't talk about that with every stop
but I think that all the people who have
made a decision to come to a bleed Creek
conversation that's a very particular
group of people sure and and those
people are like guys I'm I'm on board
not just to watch you eat I'm on board
because of who you are and your
friendship and so we get that it but
it's an interesting dance right because
if you if you lean completely into that
you we probably wouldn't here's the
ironic thing okay now if I could speak
Spanish or French I'd be better at
saying this but the ironic part of this
is that because we've chosen to create
good mythical morning in a certain way
is designed to kind of go out there and
take advantage of the way people's
online behavior on the platform of
YouTube the way the algorithm serves up
videos and the way people click on
things the titles and the thumbnails and
the and all that stuff that goes right
into that point of decision of somebody
clicking on the video because we've done
that for seven years sixteen seasons we
then have the privilege to write a book
make a documentary get people to buy the
book get people to watch the documentary
put it on a channel where you've built
this momentum doing all these things and
take finding the balance I feel like is
the real is what we're trying it we're
trying to find the balance that's what
we're trying to achieve and just to
clarify the bout is it a balance between
two things what are those two things
that you're saying I'm saying that you
can't just go completely on one side of
the spectrum which would be like
confessional every well well I was gonna
go to the other side first okay the the
I'm just trying to get you to click on a
video that's all I want you to do is
just click on a video and I don't kind
of care whether you are an existing fan
or a new fan I just want you to click on
a video and then you've got the complete
opposite of the spectrum it's like I
don't care about the algorithm I don't
care about the machine I don't care
about the game I just want to be my
unfiltered authentic self and I don't
care about schedule I don't care about
how often we upload I don't care about
it being a reliable thing that can be
there every single day it's just this
completely authentic if I feel like it I
will make a video that's and that is a
part of YouTube and there are people who
are successful in that place it's like I
couldn't make a I couldn't make a video
for the past month guys because I've
been doing X Y & Z we don't ever do that
we say we probably shouldn't have made
videos for the past month because we're
doing X Y & Z but we still gave you 20
videos this month you know or 40 or
whatever the number is so yeah I don't
know exactly well to bring it full
circle back to self-promotion right
which
where this conversation started I do
think that whatever the answers end up
being to these questions and what is
striking a balance and how does that
work I would I will say that I am
personally much more interested in and
excited about that documentary going out
to our audience and then being able to
make the connection between oh this is
the world you guys grew up in this is
like you tweeted if you want to know why
we are who we are then watch this making
that connection between us and then the
work that we put out right bleak Creek
is a incredibly deeply personal
expression of our highest creative
aspirations not only is it something
that we feel great about that we crafted
it but we feel great about the fact that
it is so tied to who we are and I would
much rather be able to do that on our
terms
being able to take that documentary and
put it on a in place of a show where we
usually just sit at a desk and do
something having the privilege to be
able to do that I'm much more excited
about that exercise than I am going on
somebody else's show wearing the right
thing saying the right thing to get the
right audience excited about the book
I'm going to keep doing that we're gonna
keep doing traditional promotions for
the things that we need to do but what
am I personally excited about I'm
excited about you know the medium that
we have freedom in yeah I mean
unfortunately we're not the the real
choice before us the thing that like I'm
you know just trying to that we're
wrestling with it's not a choice between
do we promote on other people's podcasts
or do we make our own writing it's like
there's not actually a dichotomy we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna do both
well I guess what what just happened in
this conversation was we kind of pulled
back the curtain more on like where our
minds are you know with it with our own
content which again is what
that's what we care so much about and
it's like promotion is always gonna be a
part of that but we might be dressing a
little more elevated than we we would
have expected maybe maybe we'll just go
maybe less next time let's just go let's
go in long johns yeah that would that
would be let's just go in there will
they let us on
if the flaps are up I don't know what
the conclusion of this conversation is
like you said we've let you in on I
think we look we've opened the flap of
the front of our long johns and let you
into this intimate conversation about
the creative process that way to make
them feel great about it well I want to
get out of it you know thank you I don't
want him to get to it we're opening
we're opening the back flap now you're
gonna you're gonna exit it go right out
but we got a we got a wreck eyes it's my
wreck yeah
all right baby a wreck maybe one two
three four all right fine you know what
I'm gonna why don't I just turn the
record self-promotion yeah that would be
appropriate
well I do think since you've listened
this far on this ear biscuit maybe you
have an appetite to hear us talk more
and more so I I would recommend those
three podcasts we did I think we were
proud of those conversations if you if
you're really into we talk about the
novel in each of them you know of course
we're promoting that but if you're
really into horror and like our thoughts
on that it's a horror is a hard word for
me Trish a demi JS is going if you're in
it just like rhett and Link and random
off the rails mode the books on a subway
am I getting that right books on the
subway books on the subway and if you if
you want an unfettered into uncharted
rhettandlink conversation territory
because Pete Holmes loves to talk about
faith and I'll you know philosophy yeah
so he gets into it and brings us along
for the ride so we talk about lots of
things in that to our conversation on
you made it weird so
those are my three wrecks after all that
what are you freakin promote I've yeah
Ramona miss you know you know you're
promoting three other people's podcasts
yeah yeah but I'm only promoting us on
them right but maybe they will get into
those worlds they'll open up those flaps
see what's inside those long johns you
know I'm really not long johns - I'm
really interested on what you thought
about this conversation use hashtag
bleak Creek and let us know whenever we
talk about like what we're thinking
about good mythical morning I started
getting nervous because I get nervous
that we're making fans nervous because I
know that if someone is like hey this is
part of my daily routine I don't want it
I don't want there to be any inkling of
anything that threatens that and I don't
that's not what we were talking about
we're just trying to get nervous we're
just you know just because mom and dad
are in the kitchen having a little bit
of an li ke they've raised their voice a
little bit it doesn't mean they're
getting divorced necessarily right okay
no I think that we have it if they do
it's your fault I think that this is an
effort well ear biscuits has slowly
evolved in itself right and has become a
place that we're more that we're just
we're just talking it's just two buds
talking in fact that's probably the
biggest change that we're gonna make in
2020 is this it's gonna be two buds
talking formerly known as ear biscuits
that's the first big announcement that
we can make no we're not gonna do that
and no nothing nothing's gonna change in
a way that nothing's being threatened
it's just we're letting you in we're
letting you into the conversation a
little bit
hashtag Bleek Creek that's your way to
engage oh yeah we cuz we are we don't
know what the timeline on this is but we
are gonna do an episode where we do a
spoiler ridden not a spoiler free but a
spoiler full discussion of the book for
anyone who has read the book and so
we're gonna keep giving you some time to
do that make notes of your questions or
observations anything you know it's not
just gonna be questions and if you
haven't read the book you don't want to
read the book I'm hearing
a lot where you can hear the book yeah
inaudible more put more self-promotion
yeah well we've you know when you want
to talk about it and we want to talk
about it as a family kids come
downstairs mom and dad that's something
when they want to discuss with you it's
the book they wrote to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]